hopefully I won't get into too technical
but please ask me for details if you
like another thing some of you might
have seen versions of this talk but I've
tried to put at least a few things that
you hopefully haven't seen yet so bear
with me
even though everything books anywhere so
I'm going to talk about a very simple
question suppose you have the circuit
analysis problem that's how Orion called
it or property of boolean functions so
something like this and you're trying to
figure out whether a given boolean
function has a property or not and there
are two ways that you may to situation
which you might find yourself if you are
doing this one of them is a wonderful
mcsp you are given a truth table and
you're trying to figure out what this
truth table is and another one which is
more like a sexing for friend that may
be cryptic people care about more is
you're given the circuit that computes
the function and you are trying to say
something about the function it can be
something like is it a constant function
is it it's a truth table o0 Sonali the
circuit table is it monotone it's 0 no 0
input and already among those you could
see that figuring out whether a given
circuit compute something that non
constant well that's a problem that know
and love satisfiability figuring out
with a given circuit is 0 and all their
own input you know just plug it in and
see but one thing this plug in 18 is
that if instead of a actual circuit
description you are just given an Oracle
access to the circuit it just is easy to
plug in an input and see it's not like
it's very deep
to be able to see inside the circuit and
have a box in each box things in so here
is the problem they are given one of our
favorite problems about boolean function
in a succinct representation so they be
given the function succinctly and we are
trying to figure out something about it
and the question is whether we have any
advantage when we have a circuit small
circuit computing a function figuring
out for figuring out since properties
versus basically have Oracle access to
the functions so
there is yeah so the question is is it
ever advantageous to actually have a
circuit in your hand and I'm talking
about circuit but I'll mention other
things because for some things it
actually helps the circuit that's a good
question so one motivation for this as
far as I know Russell knows more about
it than I do is Rice's theorem in
computability theory so in computer
ability if you taught computer ability
of course you know when you teach Rice's
theorem students come to you and say why
do they have to learn all those
reductions I can't just appeal to the
serum and not do all this work have that
experience
so essentially Rice's theorem and
computability theory says if you have if
you stir the description of Turing
machine there is not much you can get
out of it you have to run it and see
what it does is there a complexity
analog of this and another question
whether I serum another way of stating
it is if any problem about Turing
machine is at least as hard to the
halting problem
how can problem is the easiest property
of languages idiot profit of Turing
machines again there's a complexity
analog so I'm going to stick with the
version of scaling down to complexity
which was in a paper of Russell and
bunch of other people on possibility of
a prescription and most of many of the
statement end well the whole problem
came from there
so the way that will translate to
complexity we will talk about boolean
functions instead of languages and
circuits instead of Turing machine
non-trivial in our setting will be well
sometimes trivial if you don't need to
see the circuit if you can just create
the Oracle
so to model of access what I call clear
box not to be confused as white box a
given description of circuit they're
trying to decide the property of a
function that computes and another one
is blood box you are given an Oracle
access to the circuit and again you're
trying to decide the propertied computer
I said Oracle access to the circuit kind
of on purpose because one caveat here is
that the black box algorithm can
actually see the size of the box in
which the circuit is located so at the
very least it knows that your circuit is
no bigger than this parameter as given
to it and besides it makes inputs to
clear box and plug box to be roughly the
same size
any questions comments is a problem kind
of clear okay
so we know that there are things that
are harder than the black box having
four on demise algorithm if you know
there is only one place where something
as a zero or one
good luck finding it so let's let me
just quickly mention a couple of example
just to say how there is an interplay
between the two settings testing
something on an input same linear
complex can both setting clear in Oracle
versus evaluates a circuit if you have a
set of functions of exponential circuit
size those of you who like natural
natural proofs would jump at this
version the first thing that comes to
mind then it really helps to have that
extra parameter s which tells you which
gives an upper bound on the size of the
circle if a functions are actually
really really hard back to to the end
complexity then delete the same almost
the same algorithm in clear box and
black box you look at the parameter s if
it's small you reject otherwise you have
all the time in the world to construct
the circuit created the truth table in
all places construct the short and do
whatever you like and the third example
is if the property of boolean functions
either or of the truth table that
satisfiability that we know in love and
most of you know more about
satisfiability tonight available
okay
so here is a hypothesis that was stated
in that impossibility of obfuscation
paper suppose you have a property of
boolean function which is easy to decide
given a circuit does it mean that it's
also easy to decide given the upper
bound on the circuit size and the
auricle axis in here we are talking
about circuits you could pick your
favorite circuit bounded and bounded
fanon or whatever basis doesn't really
matter as long as it's those circuits
which are the hard things to do and
another thing is that here as you saw in
the example this hard function we really
only care what happens all functions of
sub-exponential circuit complexity let's
say we could still get an exponential
size circuit for the function of
sub-exponential circuit complexity and
we have to do the right angle theta so a
couple of words about the previous work
the the term scaling down Rice's theorem
to complexity I think first came up
Borchert and Stephan in 2000 they proved
some and big hardness result for kind of
a similar problem where they essentially
if you translated from languages
complicated languages to circuit talked
about symmetric so when I'm saying
symmetric capital F that means then if
you look at the capital F as a function
of string condensed 2 to the N which are
truth tables of functions then that
capital F behaves like a symmetric
function of those two do they make
strings so any non-trivial symmetric
property of on circuits is you pick hard
the respective poly time children
reduction
and then there were a couple of
improvements later and then this is the
paper that gave us got us into it this
long list of people but on Russell Road
only one here so cap stated the actual
black box hypothesis sort of the way
video and they call it skill down Rice's
theorem they also show that if you
replace B P P algorithm this promise be
P P then you could prove that this is
false and they constructed family of
circles which were the same as enough of
skateable family if family function
exists such that it always better to see
the circuit as opposed to just try to
access a black box
so black box hypothesis
sounds like an not an easy hypothesis
just all the various ways it implies all
sorts of P not equal NP and other cool
stuff but can we at least look at it as
a second interpretation of the Rice's
theorem and computability the one the
housing problem and say you know what if
any property is easy in the clear box a
tenant circuit but our favorite property
is easy and our favorite property here
would be satisfiability circuit shot can
we say that any deciding any property of
boolean functions is at least as hard
non-trivial property is at least as hard
and deciding satisfiability so this is
the quest so the way to state is well if
you know that if one but both hypothesis
is true that is there is no difference
between clear box black box access you
know black box access sinks exponential
hard circuits artists exponential heart
all the conjectures proof we can retire
but suppose that the circuits at is
exponentially hard for example what can
we say about the black box hypothesis
can we prove some kind of control
particular can be proved that if black
both hypothesis doesn't hold that is
there is some property of boolean
function which is non-trivial and still
it's much easier to figure it out by
looking at the circuit then querying the
Oracle even now in the circuit size then
it gives tells us something about
circuits at so what we get is that for
some class of nice potential counter
examples indeed if we could figure out
a nice property fashion circuits and
black box then we could do something
non-trivial for circuit
okay so questions comments
so let me just because this seems to say
that if self itself is indeed hubs and
the Black Lotus is true but doesn't get
confirmed it but doesn't the black box
global supporter doesn't contradict
their resultant office Kishin because
great relationship vocation is a promise
problem so indeed the promise problem
was already proven that if it doesn't
call for promise VPP then if one day
functions exist then you have enough
escapable family but this is a very
promise problem there is a distribution
of unforgettable things we don't know
how to do the non promise setting the
difference would be a problem defined on
the full domain of boolean functions I
think those two problem only to find
I'm just gonna say this is one the
promise in that result is pretty extreme
right like it's not it's not one of
these simple promises where you're just
throwing away something that doesn't
personally work yeah well the promise is
there are those two tiny fairly tiny
classes of things and it's either from
this class and then say yes oh it's from
that class and it's no why do you
suspect that the conjecture is too
well you know strong DT if people
believe strong ETH which says the
circuit sizes exponentially hard
circuit such exponentially hard by not
other things you know before you ask
that questions you say you actually
believe well I believe that the reason
it's called the hypothesis is can I
quote you
so Russell has a very great way of
common things hypothesis sometimes
hypothesis if resolving it either way is
interesting okay so why do we believe
that there is a relation that if
something is
well that seems to just come up and so
many things and be related to so many
things that it's kind of natural to see
it popping up here as well and and
indeed we could establish a connection
in some settings besides those early
results for tuning machines and such
they probably completeness by reducing
sat to kind of an earlier version of
this problem
so you said does show up there just one
reason we think it might be true is I
think you'll show this trooper or some
version of it is true whenever the
property is sensitive and there's also
the sensitivity conjecture which implies
the things that aren't sensitive that
small decision trees which is pretty
close to being polynomial time with an
Oracle yep
now that you've had the synopsis of my
talk from Rosco yeah does this answer
your question okay
so let me just with all the people
talking about mcsp I figured they have
to say something about mcsp as early as
I possibly can and they stalk so imagine
that your property is some kind of
version of succinct MCS p16 meaning that
rather than getting the whole truth
table you may get a circuit and ask is
there a small circle computing same
function so here's a way of get circuits
at algorithm from a bpp algorithm sold
in succinct mcsp just take a random
string on fresh variable just big enough
that true to the this number of
variables over N is bigger than the
parameter for which are trying to
determine the circuit size the parameter
T from mcsp now if a Vasser could see on
different set of variables for which you
try to show satisfiability now you end
those two things two thing can happen
either your circuit is unsatisfiable and
the whole thing's unsatisfiable then is
computed by something of size whatever 0
or 1 but every want to count but tiny
all your circuit is satisfiable in which
case you actually have to compute your
second circuit but you randomly guessed
it and there's probably hard function so
it probably doesn't really it's not
really computable by anything smaller
than size seated R which again takes you
just over the parameter T so mcsp can
give you an answer and you could see
that you can do the same thing there's
different versions of mcsp and circuit
with governments and so on still work
and also it generalizes if rather than
just talking about mcsp
you talk about
any property which only applies to easy
functions the only thing there is you
have to figure out at least one circuit
for which you know the value of the
function also over the property and then
you just use it the same way so what we
want to prove is if there is a property
which is decidable in VPP so in clear
box and it requires exponential
complexity in black box then circuit
satis ezvid cannot get there but what we
can prove if there is a property which
additionally has what we call the easy
sensitive instance that is there is a
string function f which both has a small
circuit complexity and if you look at
this as a string with respect to as a
string it's sensitive with respect to
capital F okay so thank you I'll be
sorry
and either the function little F is an
easy sensitive instance for the capital
F if first F little F cuts a box
financial circuit complexity and second
if you look at the truth table of little
F there are lots of bits I'd bits in the
truth table sided flipping that bit will
make it lose the property they say yes
we say if the recession little F then we
can get a circuit that algorithm out of
so for parity anything can be little
well anything of small complexity can
belittle f4 or string of all zeros and
belittle F for majority string with half
0 T to the N over two zeroes followed by
2 to the know what you want so those
capitals saying there on the truth table
yeah we're just it's the standard
definition of sensitivity we're just
thinking of the function as the input
and the property will be function to the
Train
at least about financial and then we get
circuits at algorithm so let me just yes
or a sort of already said that the
sensitivity is related list one way to
or under my decision tree complexity so
if function is hard if sensitivity
conjecture is true then they expect
something sensitive to be there okay so
let me just quickly say what are the
ingredients of the proof
and the last part so we get the circuits
at algorithm non-uniformed
sub-exponential circuit dual circuit it
would be a small circuit complexity they
may be of tiny sensitivity yeah like
many neighbors of or for example they
have sensitivity one yeah so you have
two parameters there both which are two
little little o of them how much is our
they are their relationships within
those parameters or as you need the the
second one doesn't get much better even
if the first one is a lot smaller well
it's mainly the second one that gives us
something useful
they both plug in into path or a potluck
simplification but essentially what we
need is this to be at least two to the
Delta N and there is better result that
one can obtain as Delta times two to the
N and except in monotone case we don't
know how to get things for smaller
second to the little o of n doesn't
improve if the first you had smaller
bounds on the size know that they no I
don't think anything changes if you go
from some exponential people and oh no
you get something non-trivial we need
the sensitivity to be considerably
bigger than the circuit size so that's
why once it'll make
if one was epsilon and the other was
five epsilon it would probably be fine
yeah
oh yeah so let me just very quickly give
you a picture of the algorithm
essentially the idea is if you have a
circle small circle because it's easy
for which is a description of a string
which is very sensitive and you absorb
it with a circuit for which you're
testing satisfiability with high
probability
the satisfying assignment for the
circuit you're testing they'll flip a
sensitive bit in the circuit for that
easy sensitive instance which is here
and advise so in general they don't know
how to sew the random we do two things
first we permute the inputs and second
because they don't want to flip two bits
they only want to flip one bit video
voluntours Irani so the randomness is
over those two
so I
circuit CI here will be easy it has only
one input but one times Phi assignment
then you XOR it with the random you
exhort the input to the circuit CI with
a random string R which basically
permutes the truth table of CI is your
single - this - i'ma go end up in a
random looking and then it's with high
probability will be this answer -
location which flips and then you check
the property went from 0 to 1 then that
and if you if you don't have a single so
saying simon quito valid for surrounding
first
okay it has nothing to do with circus Oh
South African is reducing circuit that
yeah it reduce the circuit set to sold
in whatever the property capital F is
because we are using the algorithm for
that property inside
it doesn't so example you might assume
that are sensitive but then they don't
know where the property capital F
actually has a string like so here is
one example which may be good to think
about so think about capital F as a
symmetric function then they know that
for every K which is a number of points
there is something with a very small
description which is just X less than K
so we have and we know that those things
are super sensitive like lengths of this
truth table over to and this polynomial
size circuit they could use it as advice
because all circuits at if a thing like
that can be decidable in VPP given a
circuit but there is more than that
just yesterday I'm Hercules oh there he
told me and mike sucks mentioned it
before that you could get something not
something uniform from here by doing a
really clever downward cell-free
disability which gives you much more
than Circuit set in BP people people
actually if you could decide some
symmetric property or boolean function
given a circuit in VPP then circuits
artisan bppm and they proved a lot more
than that but yes our idea okay let me
just mention the one thing which is what
you ask when do easy sensitive instances
exist it's a very very good question for
which we don't have an answer and I hope
somebody here would have an answer
because really what the concern was here
is it we look at things that have very
large decision tree on the tiny little
fraction and a well-structured fraction
of strings so it's not like we look at
decision tree of all shapes and sizes we
look at those palm like decision trees
they chef-like only linear polynomial
also but financially few leaves and
still they have the depth
pretty much the whole thing or
exponentially exponential and little m
maybe this is enough to get us an easy
sensitive instance so a lot of times but
i still can't grow through pretty
pictures so if somebody can solve it
that would be fantastic
can with this assumption prove something
about existence of a sensitive instance
and they probably need to exploit the
structure of a subgraph of the boy and
rightfully so
kennedy just like one more minute
so I was so frustrated with not being
able to do that I actually try to draw a
subgraph of boom hypercube a function
small description size so this is when I
did foreknow because it's easier this is
when you have end or not and you start
with inputs so this is what it looks
like and if you throw in both inputs and
negated input so that there is no
stranger symmetry you get something like
this a prettier picture but they don't
have time to show so this is the
subgraph of boolean hypercube computable
by functions on four variables vertices
are truth tables of function and T is a
number of extra gate so I'm considering
if it's an input there are 0 extra gates
if there is like 1 and oven or there is
one extra gate so you start with judge
the inputs then you end things together
Northam then you end or again and again
and here you start getting address and
you start getting more and more
interesting yeah it is so when you start
like those are not connected still not
connect still not connected now when you
throw nades three gates you started
getting neighbors and then it can be
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
versatility there what is sensitivities
sort of rear disc head I don't
it's non-trivial so if you have
something trivial it has a small
decision tree complexity that has tiny
sensitivity so things like from your
paper they have two smaller sensitivity
to have a circus art algorithm that
better wait so yeah it was as a sanity
check small uniform this randomized
decision tree
but relativity is I kind of bullying
older for that
thanks again our next talk is by shriek
on Srinivasan on the